is that what they do that's what they do
all right back
before we get it so you know how I said
leave reviews yeah I think we got two or
three or hundred reviews off that yeah
it's crazy and we promise about people
cool [__] we gotta like fulfill because
people are like here's my receipt I left
you guys good I got about a hundred
messages of people with the reviews I
replied to all of them last night I will
sit on my couch I'm just the [__]
didn't I replied all them with the
special gift
I just left I yeah call them and
basically that's a great video voicemail
you know uh at YC they have this thing
which is like you'd rather have a
thousand people love you than a million
people just kind of like you yeah and I
think that's the one thing that that is
now abundantly clear about this podcast
is like we have these goals of like
we're gonna grow this thing big but we
already did the hard part which is you
get a small number of people to love you
or they're like this is my routine this
is my favorite podcast and I've been
listening to the podcast for five years
and so that's very I don't have feels
good feels great yeah I had a I got I
was shown at him last night I got I
don't know I mean at least a couple
hundred feet like DMS on my Twitter
people with the review exam I said them
all video so review us the video or
review us and let me know because Sean
hasn't been doing it but at least if you
let me know you'll get something back
alright you know what's my fear and all
this stuff
so I have a fear that's crept up now the
fear is I never want to be the smart
person in the room and so there's part
of me I'm sitting in this red [__]
throne and throwing out ideas that I'm
admittedly saying are half-baked
yeah probably bad ideas but they're
interesting to me I want to make sure
that we're learning doing this like I
want to be learning stuff and sharing it
I don't want to just be sitting here
saying hey I got answers let me give
them to you and so my commitment to
myself really more than anybody else but
I want to say it out loud because that
commits me is you know as we do this
it's not about oh I have great ideas let
me say them or we're brainstorming great
ideas it's we're gonna learn injury
stuff by talking interesting people and
doing research on things and then we're
gonna share what we like we're gonna
share what's fun
what's interesting to us so that's my
fear is you never want to be the Guru
you want to be the student and so that's
kind of my my little mini rant I agree
I'm not trying to be a guru and I'm
certainly not because some of the deems
we get people are like help me yeah help
me you know I'm like no no I don't know
anything and me attaching my name to
your thing does nothing like we got to
do the work yeah and like you know I'll
help you but I hate I'm not the answer
I don't know yeah I'm not the right
uh-uh and we could preface this by
saying most of the ideas we get I just
steal from other people
yeah for sure of course all right you
want to again what do we want to talk
about you want to talk about can I'll
talk about something that's happening
recently
yeah Brandis so talk about think about
brainless and I want to talk about these
new credit cards that are popping up yep
all right pick one let's do it you go
ahead brainless
all right so brand list people don't
know they went out of business what they
were trying to do was they were like
look don't pay for the name-brand
you should just have high quality
products and they should just be brand
less and because we take away the
name-brand we can lower the price that
was like the initial promise or the
premise of the business awesome idea
awesome idea I'm glad you said that
because a lot of people are [__] on
them now because they like failed no but
I still think [__] awesome idea and
actually of course ironically brand les
is a great brand and so I think that
that was really cool they raised a [__]
ton of money from Softbank like 200
million dollars before they really
achieved any product market fit and that
sort of like was the death note for the
company because it was just the
expectations when you raised 200 million
is you're gonna be you know a billion
dollar plus company and if you do that
too early and you haven't actually
proven out your model you haven't
figured it all out what expectations
crush the business I actually so I
didn't prepare because I just thought
about this but what do you what's the
biggest grocery store chain in America
you think Albertsons may be Safeway I
don't know okay let's do safely can you
look up try and find this just just a
headline trying to tell me what the
revenue or how many sales like generic
brands for grocery stores or like the
Kirkland brand or woke up how much
revenue the Kirkland brand does well I
mean I bet you it's astronomical and so
actually I would I mean if you think
about
brainless could become it is the generic
the generic trusted Kirkland brand yeah
I think and I think it's a great idea
yeah the problem was that they raised
all that money Ralph the bat I have a
problem there was some incompetence with
leadership I don't actually know this
yeah Kirkland brand sells 39 billion
dollars of products
Henry quick with the trigger I like yeah
well source what's the so you think he's
lying Wow 38 billion dollars in one year
so so one thing I loved is I okay and
that's just Kirkland Kirkland crazy so I
listen to her on a podcast Tina Sharkey
I think this one and she's like an
Internet oh gee she'd been around with a
bunch of companies all of which I think
have not done super great but she went
on this podcast she said this thing that
I liked which was she was like think
back to when you were a child and like
let's walk from room to room you're in
the laundry room what brand are you
gonna see you're gonna see whatever ya
tied you're gonna see whatever go to the
pantry what are you gonna see you're
gonna see fruit roll-up and pop-tarts
and all this stuff and then open up your
fridge what are you gonna see and you
see these brands and actually it's kind
of like you've seen these stats where
the S&P 500 turns over like I don't know
20% of the S&P 500 turns over every
every decade basically the same thing
happens with these like household brands
these brands that seem like staples of
your home right a lot of them are like
like Minute Maid it's like [__] Minute
Maid you're out like you know now you
know Tang yeah Tang you know like these
brands just like like they are not they
can come and go generationally they
don't just all make it from one mom to
the next mom and I actually believe that
premise and she was like look the moms
of this generation they don't want to
pay for this like the this consumer
packaged good brand in the same way they
want out know it's high-quality
ingredients sourced you know ethically
and you know they don't want to overpay
they want to be you know value conscious
so I liked a lot on premise I'm sad I
didn't work but somebody I believe I
believe you should just go out today and
pitch I'm bran list without Softbank and
I think I would I would invest
incredible entrepreneur
you I think I had three people reach out
to me that said hey can you ask can you
introduce me to the people who are
selling for unless I mean I don't know
them but I just tweeted it and I got an
intro and I introduced three different
people who are wanting to buy the assets
now written what are the what are the
assets what are you getting you get the
name maybe a little inventory probably
okay the name and email list and then
unfortunately probably a bunch of an
incompetent team right no disrespect but
look if they couldn't pull it off there
by definition
well you'll you'll need to restart for
sure right you'll need a clean slate and
you need to lower the burn yeah I think
it's cool I would probably charge a met
did you membership they did a
subscription because they started off
with everything was three bucks I forgot
to mention that that was like a key
selling points like dude I think
everyone's three but looks like three
dollar store and people say the CAC was
too high it costs too much to acquire
customers that's probably true but like
wish is doing it yeah you know I don't
know the economics but this brings up an
interesting half-baked idea
we got a DM from your friend about like
businesses that are in the spot brand
Lissa's in where they're doing
essentially a closed down slash fire
sale and you want to share the idea that
Narendra oh sure this good idea this
morning yeah that was a great idea okay
so we got actually should bring this guy
in I have an investment of a good friend
of mine I called email them and we
became friends he invested he started a
company called webshots
and i I think he sold it for eighty
million dollars and then he bought it
back
yeah if those guys come bring him in he
bought it back for pennies and then sold
it again for twenty or thirty million
dollars and then now has bought it back
again and he was like you guys are you
know what something would be interesting
is if you could be like a graveyard or
an unwinding service Undertaker
Undertaker where you can just buy these
dying things and that exists it's a
service to basically wind down your
company you take a fee and you do this
sort of fire sale and I'm sure there's
services out there like this but
somebody could specialize in tech
companies wind down both you have talent
you have hardware you have you know
assets that you're trying to fire sell
off and then you have all the normal
business closing stuff you got to do so
you don't get like taxes next year
because you have to actually shut down
your company officially and nobody wants
to do that it's not fun and investors
want to make sure that that process is
done with no like funny business so that
they like maximize the value and this
kind of reminds me of something that I
want to bring up which is I think that
now that private companies are staying
private for long and not going public as
much what I think needs to happen is I
think the venture capitalists a lot of
VC firms need to start buying companies
and just need to own them for the cash
flow versus wanting something to go
public or get bought and so what I think
is gonna happen is I think a lot of
these VC firms are almost going to turn
into hedge funds or private equity funds
we're gonna they're gonna buy and
operate a lot more than they are now and
that's related to that so I don't think
VCS will do it but the sort of New Age
VCS that are gonna be hybrids so like
andreessen horowitz shifted their model
or they're not a VC they're now I forgot
what it's called but like they wanted to
be able to just own cryptocurrency just
buy and hold it so they needed to
reclassify and then this gotcha moth he
basically has a fund called social
capital it started off as a traditional
VC fund and then like he had to restart
it for all kinds of reasons but one of
the things he does now is he has this
thing called ass back which is his
special purpose vehicle for taking
companies public so you're a company you
don't want to go public he's already
public and he just acquires a stick you
know of stake in your company I believe
is that this is how the mechanics work
so they just did this with Virgin
Galactic and so it's like a fast track
to being public and getting that
liquidity without having to go and be
you know your own independent listing
yeah I'm into that I know Andrew
Wilkinson is probably listening he owns
tiny capital and they do they've been
doing this the companies that they own
collectively I think do about 100
million in revenue and he I think takes
dividends and buys companies with the
cash flow right and it's an awesome
model but a lot of these companies like
brand lists there's no cash flow right
it's gonna be a cash sink it's one of
these go big or go to zero and in this
stuff in this case it went to zero yeah
but at the same class fee it doesn't
have to be but it's also that is also
valid right like to do the do what like
jet tried to do just like you know
they never made their core business work
sold for three billion dollars because
they they went for the plough money and
today try to get the scale and then be
the first to have scale doing what we do
I know it's a it's a model what's the
other one you want to about credit cards
um we couldn't mention it just for a
second but uh ramp ramp capital right
ramp let's ramp something it's based out
of nearest Breck's but from New York
yeah I'm into it it launched today okay
so I went my company we do let's say
eight figures a year in revenue we have
not seven figures in cash well I have
been using one big bank for a long time
and to get us to raise our credit-card
limit from 30,000 to 80,000 was a
nightmare oh my god a nightmare yeah I
had to go meet them in person two or
three times I had to show that my
personal Sam Parrs tax returns it was
stupid
I signed up to Breck's and I got three
or four hundred some hundreds of
thousands of dollars in like 12 hours
yeah awesome
and I told these guys in like yeah we
can't compete with that oh okay all
right
this conversation is over thank you so I
really like this new business credit
card space and I explained how I think
they're making money but ramp just
launched and what they're gonna do what
they said they're gonna do is they're
gonna analyze all your credit card
spending and they'll tell you where
repetitive purchases are coming through
and I actually mentioned this on the
podcast three months ago I was like I'm
telling you that businesses are wasting
so much money by buying multiple
subscriptions of things and I think
something amazing can be built by
helping you save a little bit of money
right that's what this is that's like a
side feature they have that's not like
the main feature is the same like bricks
right like it's like here's a business
credit card well that's how they're
differentiating Breck's is advertising
says we will get you better rewards
right and this is will save your money
yeah and I think it's cool and I'm
really bullish on those things and I
think the way they work is whenever a
whenever a customer when I have my
credit card and I go and buy something
the merchant pays a 4% fee
and what Breck's does is they go to
master car and they go hey you guys are
getting four percent fee for all this
stuff
give us a cut of that and we'll create
more credit card users right and I think
that's how they're making money I'd
imagine I think so I don't know I don't
know for certain but FinTech companies
are very intersting we should I know a
couple guys are deep and FinTech we'll
bring them on a lot of people are not
deep into that and not go like well
front and betterment a lot of people
hate those like buyers all right I don't
know how they're ever gonna get bought I
don't know who would buy them we'll see
all right what else we got up here let's
sleep I feel like Sean when we come for
the last few times I've been the one
doing all the research and I feel like
that you're the one who's done all the
research I did some research this time
so first follow up on last time I was
talking about corporate universities I'm
gonna keep talking about anything
education because I just love it I had a
lot of people reach out to me about that
really okay so I went back to my notes I
already had these notes but I just
wanted to mention a couple of them so
hamburger you that's the McDonald's 119
full-time professors I thought that was
interesting there's I don't how you say
this Croton ville that's from General
Electric
so Kaiser just opened up their own med
school which I find really interesting
because it's what that's exactly what I
was talking about where you want your
own pipeline of doctors so you create
your own med school then some companies
do it more like training Apple
University Deloitte University I think
those are more like just a training
program so you could be a better
employee that's that's different another
one that I thought was interesting so we
talked about Zoho so Zoho has their own
University and the graduates of that
make up 15% of their workforce [__]
which is pretty insane so a hundred
people I'm not sure exactly how many
total it is to Google IT support
certificate has 75,000 graduated
students which is pretty crazy so I
think this is gonna be a big trend so
it's the opportunity to be a company
that can create these education so I
think what you can do is so there's
these companies that are called what the
hell are they called
I know one is called to you or something
like that that's the name of one of
their companies so there's a set of
companies that what they're doing is
they say hey university hey Berkeley you
should have an online degree and for
years universities were not so
interested in this
and then they saw how much money gets
made by online degrees and so they're
like okay we'll take that money and so
they don't want to you know Berkeley
doesn't want have to sit there and build
out an online degree portal that has
like the technology the service acquire
students like Berkeley doesn't know how
to do any of that [__] right so there's
a couple there's three big companies
that basically go to these universities
and they say hey do you want to offer an
online degree we think it brings this
much incremental revenue to your
University and we will run the whole
thing for you so you don't have to lift
a finger and here's the but we want you
know 30 percent of the tuition revenue
and right so what happened is all the
university said yes so there's a billion
dollar company that's doing this that
basically offers this to all the
universities so this if you go look all
these you know traditional universities
now have a online degree or certificate
certificate program that they offer and
it's run by these other companies I
forgot the name of what these companies
are called there's like some generic
term but I think you could be that for
corporations and so I think you could go
to a corporation and say hey would you
like to basically have your own you know
developer bootcamp or university for you
know essentially we're gonna pop out
people who are like management
consultant types and it's good for your
brand to get students early and anytime
you hire one of them we take essentially
a recruiter fee and we'll run the whole
thing for you and so I think that's one
way you could take advantage of this
trend so vaynermedia does this thing
called 3ds or I don't know what it's
called something like that and it's ten
grand and you go to their office for a
day and you learn how their business
operates so if you're an agency owner
you get to hang out with Gary Vaynerchuk
for an hour but then they also have like
the head of each department for an hour
and they come in they explain how their
companies are run and you have book in a
pot you have book in the box here can
you answer this actually no special
guests special guests just go out you
can just go out here and answer it he's
just outside
well show who's coming in in a second
but anyway
was that saying you're about to say book
in a box Oh book in a box Oh Tucker
who's on here he is thinking about do
the same thing as well where users can
pay a fee and they can come in and see
how the company operates so book in the
box itself is a little bit different
book in a box is you want to write a
book this is book in a box we're gonna
help you write it promote it do the
cover work all that stuff and they do
this for like high-profile business type
of people who want to have their own
book right and that business does good
it's a good business
yeah he bootstrapped it they have a he
what's telling me he was like Amazon's
gonna buy us for so much money
that's like the joke that he has said
and what they want to do which is
different what you're talking about what
our idea is give you exposure inside
these companies to the like leadership
of these companies at it yeah I take you
on corporate tours yeah because book in
a box what they're famous for is their
culture is really good like their own
company culture yeah interesting and so
that's and we thought about doing it as
well I mean we're not big enough that we
have something to offer but it's kind of
a cool idea is we're like I would do it
for other companies I would pay money to
see it like a bar stool did a thing
where you could see how their how they
operate their business I would pay money
and go right and vaynermedia what if you
guys want to research this if you want
it like if you think that your company
is special and people would pay money to
do it to see how big of a nurse is they
put all their events on Eventbrite and
you could see which how many tickets are
selling per event and you can actually
reverse engineer this and see how much
revenue it's bringing in I like it okay
I have two ideas that are I've talked
about this before I'm in a big company
right now and it's my first time ever in
a big two thousand person company and so
I'm seeing all this stuff that I'm like
either are problems that need to be
solved of a big company that I never saw
before or homegrown solutions that I'm
like dude that could be a standalone
company this little home we're on thing
we built and so I want to share what one
of each with you on the podcast today so
without further ado the first one I'll
do is something that I wish I wish we
had now this is a I'll call it this is
kind of a far-fetched idea but
personally I think is valuable so
of sitting a meeting in the way meetings
work at any Amazon company I believe is
you have this like heavy written culture
so you write a doc you write a memo
before you come in and it basically says
you know here's that here's what we're
here to discuss here's the context
here's the potential solutions here's
what we believe is a recommended
solution type of thing right you you
write a memo that basically does a lot
of the pre-work of what you would
normally discuss in the meeting and the
first 20 minutes of the meeting are
everybody reading this thing so it's
silent there's like 15 people on a long
board room Amazon you read the memo and
nobody talks and then after 15 20
minutes somebody basically says like hey
is everyone done anybody need more time
and you're like now we're good to go
and then it's probably somebody needs
more time but they don't say anything
and then and then you start the
discussion and the discussion
the problem with meetings is you've guys
like me who are like want to say stuff
all the freaking time and so they just
talk way more than anybody else
[Music]
recording right here so if you're
listening to this you don't have video
Lance Armstrong just walked in as he
does you know at certain times and Lance
Lance you wanna pull up that chair for a
minute just for a minute here you can
take this where swing this around
actually you know what take the take the
ridge here I'm gonna sit on this we did
not plan this so I know Neil Dempsey
suckered me he said not sorry he just
said me don't ever sit in here it by the
way either oh this is what I do so Lance
we were so we have this podcast here
yeah every day three days a week at this
point it feels like every day right well
our goal is to get to a hundred thousand
daily listeners yeah per episode
right right and we're doing a good job
yeah we're getting close
good I bet you are you have a big big
following a big following and so the
back story behind this podcast is and
now we're doing videos and we're
chopping it up like you do with forward
the forward the forward the forward and
the move so the second one just you know
yeah the tour one's called the move and
so what we've been doing is as well do
video you get I don't get you that'll
get you to 100,000 quicker it's helping
a lot and so what we've been doing so
Sean had a company that he just sold to
twitch and I've got companies and all
we've been doing is scheming out loud
and for some reason people love
listening to it and how long are they
maybe an hour they've been it's been
working and we have like everyone's
messaging saying they're starting little
things that we've been ripping on good
and we just I'd listen to a few I you
know what I'd kind of get you I do get
I'll occasionally listen to Rogen if
it's if it's a guess that I'm interested
in the whole thing or the clip no it's
it he goes long man three-hour hours I'm
like when I did it he was like it was
like so how long do you think I'll be
here he's like three hours like what
I've never talked to anybody for three
hours like oh I'm not talking for three
hours I'm not that interesting but ya
know so I'll get into these crime ones
me too me too I got sucked into this
root of evil yep that was just super
[__] up I've been listening to that
one no yeah you try not to and then what
was the other one that was just how do
real killers you know that one no but
they're all about serial killers right
no there's one called serial killers
yeah it's awesome we crashed about we
were kind of crime I listened to all
those ones as well
the one dree and park ass yeah and they
just one of them one of those companies
just sold to Spotify auto-fire a couple
hundred million bucks so did the ringer
the ringer Bill Simmons just keeps
making money yeah apparently I think he
owned I bet you he owned the majority of
that company Wow
so he probably walked away with a couple
hundred million bucks for him we got to
get you off the lacroix have you seen
the mine I just leave them here have you
seen the new brand at Austin Waterloo
what's water it's like a sparkling water
but it's better so this is what the pack
I'm an investor full disclosure well
this is what the podcast is now they're
crushing it there so what is it it's a
it's look what is it it's sparkling
water but it's it's yeah I'm sure they
do
I mean it's all the rage well from the
Austin office it's on their their HQ is
on is on comm is on e Cesar Chavez as
well so from from where the Hustle is or
at least where it's always not moved we
moved into a bike shop okay so you guys
used to be on Cesar Chavez you moved up
but so they're still on Cesar Chavez
which is where our studio is but now
they're just they're cool guys are
killing it you know how much did they
raise they just did a new round it's 30
they raised I want to say I'm probably
getting that wrong but they did 50
million sales last year they're gonna do
100 this year holy [__] no they're
they're knocking yeah it's it's it's
it's lighter cleaner the can they have
all these different yeah we're like it's
like past era it's like a white well
they have a lot of flavors now is
probably up to ten or twelve but it's
like a retro looking can yeah it's real
sort of groovy looking they brought in
the guy that ran smart pop and sold that
off and so he's the CEO so they got real
Austin has Bob Adventures is the big
Cobb who ventures out of Austin that's
the guy from the vodka company is that
the T so he Clayton was was from D Patti
he did sweet leaf tea deep Betty and
then went and started Kabu with two
other guys he's now since left but
anyways he's still on the board at
Waterloo and hi brew coffee which is a
big advertiser of ours
know how love would even what's wrong -
boring what's wrong with you what's
wrong with this guy he doesn't like
making money you know there's probably
there's probably some charity right down
the street where you could go give them
all your dough from twitch and give them
all your time just like being an uncle
you get all the fun stuff and not on
move artwork yeah I mean we we we
launched a fund and we almost you know
probably 90% of the companies were super
involved with well either through the
board or being on the board or just they
just need help I mean you know this I
mean young entrepreneurs that they might
have a great idea and and be smart
people but they're gonna come across
things they just need help navigating
and-and-and or connecting them a minute
within our honestly the worst companies
need the most help and I can't say them
the best companies never need my help
and everybody else between the good
companies that I really don't have any
influence in I just get to take credit
in the end and I was like I dig that
honesty best companies truly like lambda
schools probably the best one is done
pretty well I'm like a needy girlfriend
Silicon Valley companies doing super
well and you know I'll text the founder
to be like hey what's up you want to jam
on ideas you want me to help you with
this problem and he's like dude I'm just
busy I hate I hate when investors ask
what what I we won't tell nil when he
gets here well I what I do is I set
monthly updates and they're very clear
and succinct and I'm very transparent
and they're like how can I help I'm like
you can't unless you have ideas and you
can tell me how you can help do it but I
don't like I can't think of anything
yeah like it's like I don't know how can
you help you and I mean it's like what
you gotta come in here and write emails
for me and do work for me I mean like I
don't know either like do you need
interests anyone I'm like who do you
know I don't know that's I mean I think
the intro part is big in our world and
so you know in health and wellness
fitness nutrition I mean it's it's you
know I've been doing this for 30 years
just as an athlete so I've gotten to
know everybody I mean if if we make it
invest these are just examples but if we
make an investment in a company like amp
human and they need and it'd be very
obvious that they'd be connected to
Strava and vice versa it would take them
a month to get a call I think you're
different though thank you Sam well
that's your value is what that's our
value yeah everyone knows that you know
everyone I mean you're a celebrity like
you could get touch with everyone but
like if you know I'm an investor you're
an investor it's like they don't know
who I know yeah and I probably don't
know that many people who they can't
just call email yeah I mean is that what
your angle is gonna be is that you have
there's that and we call I mean we refer
to it as the flywheel just cuz with you
know now the one show the second show
the move is about 15 million downloads a
year and so you know once that started
to really take off then I was getting
all this interesting deal flow I thought
to myself we should start of fund and
invest in some of these companies and
and then what happens when we
reintegrate or occasionally integrate
some of our companies back into that
audience right that course sticky group
of 15 million people and so that's
that's what well here's Neil that's what
we bring to it
yeah so yeah I mean there's the
connections there is the flywheel
there's the audience and then we got a
pretty kick-ass Advisory Board that we
pull into whether it's you know
researching deal flow or or sitting on
boards some and we won't take up too
much time
this was impromptu so he said we're
going to get a sandwich we already
ordered you food
oh yeah well Neil texted me this morning
and he's like hey can I use the guys
office I go yeah we got a conference
room we'll take care of food so we
already have everything for you though
can I just say like all these parking
garages around here with the sign on
that says open I went into like three of
them the dudes like we're full Ike well
why don't you turn off the [__] sign
like you've got ten cars in here that
now all have to back up cuz the sign
says open which crotchy parking well I
ended up parking right around the corner
right here I hope that's the parking
thing was yellow is a rental car yep
what type of card you rent well hang on
let's first figure out if I'm gonna get
a ticket so the thing was yellow I put
my card in bought an hour
well I'll hook it up we'll make it
happen no I know I got a good great
garage down the street that I parked in
okay well it's too late now I gotta go
to the airport soon but I don't know
what you really want to know what kind
of car yeah they gave me a it's like a
suburban kind of thing yeah I Drive that
at home so I didn't mind I like I know
where everything is I'm beckoned I can
you know it's like my cockpit so let me
let me run one thing buy it and then is
Neil here so you were doing a thing so
we've talked about hotels out here for
I've been riffing on hotels I'm really
interested in hotels yep because they're
growing like the biggest hotels the top
ten they're growing at a really high
clip right now because young people are
doing experiences more you George
Hincapie has this thing called the dough
mystique and you were doing a ride there
where someone could pay a fee and hang
out with you for two days
yeah we call it a camp yeah and it's
probably four days of riding right
and something that's been interesting us
me and I've been bringing up is hotels
that offer more experiences yeah and so
it could be as small as being filled
with peloton bikes yeah which I have
found myself going to more hotels just
because they have a high quality gym are
you did you see that his hotel or the
dough mystique did it get increased
bookings because of that because of that
Hampton we sold yeah and well here's the
yeah I mean it's an inch his hotels it's
only I think 12 or 13 rooms so it's
pretty easy to fill up so if we
announced and what he and I are doing
the same thing in my orc in September
but at a separate hotel but obviously
but when we announced that camp it just
kind of fills up you know it would it be
a different jam if it was a 200 room
hotel and that's his problem right he
can either sell he either has one room
full our two rooms or he could sell 200
rooms right thirteen is a tough number I
would love for that to happen and that's
what I told you I think my phone's
ringing by the way I think it might be
Neil you can answer that he wants to
come up that's what I told you I wrote
an email to you one time I was like you
need to become the Jimmy Buffett of
weekend warriors right and you need to
have a hotel where people could come and
dude Jimmy Buffett I mean he's a new I
guess I couldn't answer your call I got
roped into a podcast Neil your your big
filmed right now just say hi right there
the camera will wrap up here in a second
yeah but I mean Jimmy's he's branded
everything whether it's blenders he's
doing nursing homes now Jimmy Buffett is
yes so I mean he's got I mean the one
when I talk about Jimmy Buffett I mean
if you think about a Jimmy Buffett fan
like a Parrothead right so if it's the
day of the show in Dallas Texas which I
say that cuz that's my mom and stepdad
go every time from the minute they wake
up he's owning them right they're
listening to Sirius XM they listen to
his station right probably at some point
pregame they're drinking his beer the
landshark beer then they then he'd they
buy the ticket which is again his they
get to the show they're buying his
schwag go back they pre gated they they
they like pregame or
tailgate out there they're using his
margarita blender he's got everything
and he has a think it's a hotel he's got
his clothes closed right I mean why is
why Lance Armstrong not the Jimmy
Buffett of weekend warriors Hotel Jimmy
Jimmy I don't know if you paid attention
the last seven right you know we're
getting back there but it could happen
I'm curling you yeah like what the world
that I don't want to live it is like I
can like these UFC cannabis he's all in
a candidacy yeah the coral reefer that's
what it's called that's what it's called
the coral reefer these UFC guys are kind
of doing it where you could pay money
and go and work out with them and live
at their gym yeah layered him Laird
Hamilton's doing it you know I did for a
sec and I did now dancers no I just I
don't know that's how you can I just I
just didn't I don't know I wouldn't do
cameo that's how you could tell which
celebrity is broke by how much their how
much they like Gilbert Gilbert Godfried
charging $50 for two minutes flat this
guy's broke by the way thank you nice
nice people I talked to them you know
when I great but nobody yeah but like
it's like uncle Joey from full house is
really hurt and he's only charging fifty
bucks for a three-minute spot like he's
broke
I feel this is horrible whereas Snoop is
charged at two grand he's the one who's
doing good snoop charges two grand on
cameo no something like that yeah I got
TJ Lavin from or whatever he he's the
max I got TJ Lavin to say hi to my wife
for like a hundred dollars
he's like no in the real world it's
stupid but that's how you could tell
who's broke is by what they charge on
cameo the more they charge the more bro
there or lies if they charge a little
bit of money then they're really here
and I set mine high and it was just you
know it was two people I would anybody
pay that anyways can i Neal and I were
gonna go have lunch oh yeah well let you
mean lunch with us are you're gonna keep
podcasting I'm gonna wrap up here in a
few minutes yeah so why don't you guys I
don't want to take you see we were just
kick lands I didn't expect to do this so
we were just killing time thank you
we'll talk to you yeah that conference
room over there's all yours that was a
good surprise yeah that was fun I don't
know what's gonna happen with this yeah
this podcasts gonna be interesting it's
gonna either be great or not great and
that could be in the between so okay so
are you gonna wrap up cuz if you want to
wrap up we can we can either do two
minutes of more stuff no you do two
minutes I don't know what can you pull
up the sheet again is it Scott like this
was a crazy for those listening Sean and
I had this thing planned out and we're
gonna do a norm up so no this is great
this is life happens you you take life
we had Lance Armstrong just show up and
come and come into the Lance Armstrong
walks into your podcast you do exactly
what just happened get the [__] up you
let the data and you talk to Lance
Armstrong for 10 minutes and you don't
worry about anything else so if it
matters I mean this is what our office
is like we do get a lot of cool people
coming by yeah the guy that Lance was
with the gentleman you maybe just saw on
camera his name is Neil Dempsey he won't
ever tell me this I'm pretty sure Neil's
a billionaire and Neil's one of my
investors and Neil will have felt like a
billionaire I felt that Billy energy
will have him well I'll have him on the
podcast sometime but basically he was in
his he was trying companies and kept
failing and up and his late 30s early
40s he was failing failing failing he's
got a job at a VC and met this guy
starting a coffee shop brought to the VC
everyone laughed at him they said no
this we're not investing this stupid so
Neil invested to his own personal money
into it and that company ended up being
start Starbucks and so Howard Shola you
have Starbucks says that Neil is one of
the people he looks up to and he's one
of my investors they named the stadium
one of the stadiums at Washington in
Washington is it Washington University
or University of Washington they named
it it's called Dempsey Stadium because
he donated so he's a big deal that's
cool
this is that's legit our office that's a
great story Wow how to follow that okay
III think that we should probably kind
of wrap it up and hope that there's some
value in here for people okay okay a
little bit let me toss out one idea
because we go people ideas and let me
tell us that one good idea which one
okay I'm gonna do that I'm gonna do the
one I started so I started off talking
about ok these meetings or meetings or
meetings basically are like the bread
and butter of big companies and so I
calculated we have on on every floor we
have like 20 meeting rooms say and nine
floors so let's call it 10 floors
there's 200 meeting rooms and every hour
let's assume I don't know 80% of its
occupied so I basically did the math and
saw how many hours and then you think oh
every meeting is on average five people
in it and so you start to realize how
many people hours are spent in meetings
and then when you look at a meeting
while it's happening there's basically
no technology so the only technology in
a meeting is like video conferencing
typically and I think that's kind of
crazy and so I actually believe that
there's someone out there who could
build a meeting meeting kit of some kind
that makes meetings more more effective
more efficient and I'm not talking about
like transcribing although that's one
possibility what I'm thinking about more
is like the ability to give so I'm
imagining like a physical device and you
push it when you want to say something
so this doesn't reward interrupters and
loud voices because you sort of buzz in
when you're ready to talk so it just has
a little light next to your thing that
says Sean you sounds like you have some
it ended at the memo thing that alone is
worth it well the memo doesn't require
any like there's no business there right
like companies just adopt that Prince
you know that song and here's why I
think you're wrong is Axios is coming
out with this and there's another new
product called recess that just launched
and all it is is a software sass it's a
service you pay money and you get this
internal emailing tool that helps you
write internal emails better to your
company and it tells you who read it and
who didn't so it's more concise or what
does it help yeah cuz actually was a
super concise as is yeah I think I
basically I think that there's a meeting
tech that will sound really boring but
if you just think about how much of
business happens in meetings how many
hours how much salary is spent every
hour in these meetings if you could make
a 10 percent lift and how good the
communication was or how well that
meeting ran that's a big big lift and I
don't think anybody's really doing much
interesting stuff there I think people
only really worry about like how do you
schedule the meeting and how do you
conference into the meeting there's a
lot of running the meeting meetings and
only and those are successful but I
think the meeting itself could use some
improvement anyway so trying to throw in
an idea here but this will be known as
the Lance Armstrong podcast yeah well
actually get them in here a real time
this I hope I think we should publish
this but we'll apologize that it's only
I maybe yeah and we have a ton of ideas
to go through for tomorrow you you have
a few on here that I'm like you're
curious about yeah so well we'll get
them tomorrow all right Mauro peace out